so I like throwing some curveballs at
the beginning
um if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done before what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why oh my goodness oh
probably the thing with me and Ashton
walking the runway on Earth
plunging tops v-necks are you on deep
bees good luck wow no I'll say this I'll
say bandit just because I get to be I
get to be I get to do a lot of fun stuff
and his performance is so good I I would
I would say bandit too because I'd want
people to see where I'm at currently uh
because I don't you know all the body of
work after that or before that was just
leading up to you know I feel like every
time you get a chance to get you know
just a little bit better you think you
would hope you know what I mean you
bring all the projects sort of along
with you and the experience so I I'd
want them to see the most current thing
I'd say early in your career you were on
something called Popular Mechanics yes
sir and I'm just curious when you were
get breaking in I don't know how old you
were but like 16. is this when you took
the part from her sister no that was no
no actually yes I did take that job from
her yeah anyway I'm just curious what do
you remember from being a part of that
that because it you know that was you
know you're just breaking in and can you
imagine at that point did you ever think
you would be like here yeah
um I hoped I would you know I think that
that was the beginnings that was really
sort of for me my education on you know
film and television and understanding
all the working parts
um and the the joy of that was that I
got to be me I mean I was a host so to
be Alicia and just learning about
everything was really
um exciting because I think I didn't
have the pressure of having to be a
great actress at that time so I really
got to just focus on what it was like my
film school really sure yeah um this is
jumping into why I get to talk to you
guys this is a crazy true story like you
hear about bank robbers that do five
Bank jobs or you know just a few this he
did 59 right it's bananas can you sort
of talk about how how crazy this story
is
yeah I mean it it it's it's that's what
I loved about it it's like this cannot
be true and it is uh
and what fascinates me most is why he
did it and why he kept doing it and and
why he started doing it was because of
pure desperation he he was always kind
of a small time criminal was in jail in
the U.S broke out of jail fled into
Canada uh meets her and falls in love
and wants what he never had as a kid and
that's to have a family in a stable sort
of home
and he wanted to build that with her
couldn't find a job
well what do you do you you rob a bank
right isn't that what you do I mean I
think that's what most logical people
would do you go put on a disguise you go
rob a bank quick money
I think it helped that it was a 5 it was
85 it made a lot easier I'm not saying
that's what I'm not I'm not recommending
anybody yeah I was like let's not
what he found was it became he loved it
yeah there's a thrill that came with
that and I think he got really good at
it really quick
and started to think that he could get
away with this because he had this idea
that if he could get in and out of these
Banks
in under two minutes and get out of
whatever disguise he had on off of him
in under 30 seconds they'll never gonna
catch him
and he was right until number 60.
handsome one of the things about the
film is I was watching you guys wearing
this 80s clothing oh wow I've worn 80s
clothing and I wanted to jump out of it
about two seconds after I put it on
polyester really itchy it is terrible
what was it like for you guys because
it's really terrible clothing yeah yeah
yeah the sweaters were a lot they're
loud let's say that it's less fun you
know 35 years later yeah 40 years later
and we were in Georgia and having to
depict winter in Canada so we had to go
with heavier you know clothing which was
so kind of torturous because it was 110
degrees not winter obviously and very
uncomfortable but but you know that's
what you got to do it's pretty loud
those sweaters whoa
all right hello
here we are
I felt like uh
I was on Charlie Brown Charlie Brown are
we gonna say Bill Cosby but that
wouldn't be a good reference no I'm
gonna say we could we could skip that
one yeah yeah yeah yeah so obviously
you're making this film on a budget and
I'm curious was there a day or two that
you really had to sort of like you were
nervous about being able to pull off
everything that was on the on the on the
call sheet that day I mean
uh well I'm sorry what was the question
I guess because you're not you don't
have Transformers money you don't have
Marvel money this is you know like uh
and I'm just curious when you're looking
at the schedule was there a day or two
that you're like how are we going to get
all this done every day I mean that's
that's I mean that's that's the case on
most movies though is that you
you rarely have enough time or money and
even when you do have all the money even
when you do have the money you never
have enough time yeah and so on this one
in particular there was a lot of and I
won't get into all the reasons why but
there's a lot of things that we had to
work around yeah and
I was so proud of the way that Adam or
Alan Unger our director handled it he
was he stayed focused stayed positive
kept his eye on the prize which was
finding the best version of each scene
yeah even if we couldn't shoot it the
way even if we only got like one or two
takes you know it was like we he's so
prepared I I made sure to be prepared so
that you know when you're when you go
into films like this that can get tricky
I mean if if everyone does their
homework you can kind of get in and get
out and pivot well so I thought we were
all pivoted very well yeah it's true
that's part of the fun of it too is the
problem-solving side of it because
you're inevitably going to run into
something there's always something that
that obstacles you have to sort of
overcome in these things especially the
smaller budget ones and uh this one was
definitely uh no different yeah I think
it turned out very well awesome on that
note I gotta go thank you